[Music]
hello welcome but so glad you could make
it I see you're ready to cry are you
prepared for some tears
I'm loving this game I'm I love the
atmosphere it really takes me back I
loved where the story I don't know if I
like the story I mean I think it would
all depend on how it ends
but I just enjoy playing it so let's
keep at it
why don't we we got to find for a Mentos
if you're not familiar with Mentos it's
the things you capture when you're back
in time
a small inhabited aquarium well that
seems redundant great we're in Italy Wow
what
you can just do that that is so cute
come on Colleen that what is not that
cold that is so cute
colonists with another Sofia but he has
another love interest at a younger age
what could it mean how does it all
connect
he clearly loves the fear fear you still
awake
told you lemon juice is the way to go ha
ha ha so cute I think I found the Mentos
the master Mentos of course this
painting a faded painting of Bora Bora
that's not it is that Italy I've been
playing with a keyboard this whole time
looks like we're about to lay down some
ramps
when react oh I think there's still some
stuff in here we haven't checked stay
then okay so that this hotel is amazing
dad hibiscus this is more of a suitable
place for that kind of power flower
we found it okay we were charged but we
need to find the ultra mementos the men
men the man mentis huh yay backtracking
at least it's a beach sometimes they
they break the barrier in in strange
waves
I'm okay with it I don't remember what
the Mentos was them
what's the master Mentos oh yeah we
found it already I'm stupid it's here
backtracking everybody could you could
you catch you catch you catch you here
we go
it's time for everyone's favorite part
beep I try to sell puzzles some triggers
change memorylanes themselves what does
that mean
Oh oh my god now it's getting weird okay
we can't move upward in downwards but we
can oh I see I see I see
okay there we go you got to just put
them up here right oh and then somehow
now I am confusion there you go
genius Paris strikes again my god he
must an have an IQ level of five Rick
and Morty shows activate the blanket
everybody here we go
I'm really curious where this story is
gonna go with fiha at least there they
are
guess he made it as a pilot huh hey your
shifts just about to start at the shop
oh he's just cleaning that's funny
okay I'm almost done here I'll do it
when there's no customers
did you get yours done all right what do
we got so cute sing them together it
makes you wonder what happened where's
the Mentos dundas nah the man told us
it's a truck here really there's nothing
else here no Mentos
that's dangerous she should really get
damn from there
wow what a what a party girl you are
Rosaline keep forgetting other there
it's that new kid they hired is really
quiet yeah but at least he gets the work
done doesn't he have a scheduled flight
this afternoon yeah but where a plane
short cuz someone snagged a blown tire
unless someone gets canceled I don't
think he'll get to fly yeah does he even
have an instructor yet beats me hey
tickity baby I know Shh well Colin maybe
you can be a little bit more outgoing
you thought about that Colin if that's
your real name I don't know why I'm
saying this way what the heck is this
still has the cat face and that's how
equilibrium is achieved through four
forces of flight any questions why does
the plane have a cat's head I don't know
it was on there when I got here so I
just wrote over it
the epic prank
what about oh it's the popo a blurred
entry about working at the airport and
faye falling asleep on the wing of the
plane there's also some random class
notes read it
no I don't know I don't really care
here let me get that for you hey it's
Barry - Barry is back everybody thank
God thank God I was wondering where he's
Arc was going sorry
you just gotta unhook it from the inside
and he must have really smart hands wow
that is some crazy maneuvering kid I've
been here four years
and I could never figure that out thing
out you must even that's the wrong boys
you must have like some kind of magic
inventing Paley I already know cuz I
have to clean it so this that's totally
radical that's Bret Barrett's voice of
course
okay here's $24 and change uh wow that's
uh that's a lot of pennies it's okay I
have all day oh my god if you ever
worked behind a cashier that doesn't
count the change for you and you have to
calculate it in your head constantly
yeah you get good at it after a while
but when you start up it's really like
uh I read that as that's a lot of
penises
good job me told you guys I have
Tourette's a mild form I'm sure of it
just like that Hey I guess everyone has
their reason he stayed playing hmm and
what about you well yes between you me
very strict units in my real face Oh his
instructor in fact before I came
entities there was an acrobatic
skywriting
Pele Wow like making stuff up here in
the sky with plain trails yeah every
stand guilty but then I get back why
total discrimination I tell you it was
all cuz they found out I am an
illiterate who dropped out of school did
they care that I was the most skillful
play a pilot in the fleet yeah but just
because I don't read good they drop me
like a hot potato
wow I can relate to Barry finally a
character it burns me up just thinking
about it yeah that really doesn't seem
sound fair well maybe if I need your
service one day I'll be able to hire you
thanks kid man faith you gave me my soda
then you were to give me life my life me
and see that I gotta have to flatten
stack the heck all right well
that went well okay erotica is famous
around to fall asleep at locations we
might be in a bit of a ride there's
still a memory link missing and the
readings indicate we've activated
everything in the area
hey maybe we could stimulate his memory
somehow hopefully let's keep our eyes
open stimulate his memory
Nonnie this has never happened oh what
will say it did you feel y-yeah well I
don't know it's some kind of breeze that
was a guy running super fast it was the
flash get real here can't wrap it must
have left the building
[Music]
open earlier if I did you would know I
have been literally right behind you in
fact I don't even know why I'm just
following you in a constant manner see
there you go again game the dare you go
again Oh spooky okay oh oh oh oh oh wow
okay this is this is different
what the heck is ass
I don't know but but it seems like this
may be our ticket out of this memory so
what we need a way to continue in this
places magically open itself up in the
most unsettling way no less I'm not sure
what's going on with this place either
but there's only one way to go now come
in we get it you oh hey no I can't even
look down it's the only way to find out
Neal okay I'm jumping in three two what
I didn't push you
[Music]
oh my god that sorry
wait tone your hand down I think I can
see them in San yes this makes sense
what is even going on and why is this
happening you you're doing just bad
we're not gonna die now
do you have the red mainsail alright I
think so okay flatty up roads and don't
forget the cockpit chick mixture full
rich primer in and locked zero Yankee
Romero cleared to land runway two one
zero Yankee bromium bit too high
get some flaps Indy speed lower the
nerves
alright I have control oh thank god
what this is farce attend hold on it
looks like we're gonna wind you are
literally not holding on to anything
wrestling you you do know that at that
right Robert right well that was awesome
what is that oh poor watts hey you all
good no eBay m-net oh good
in fact I'm Dave man the humor is so
much better than stock before this game
kind of like Fred friendly humor but it
works I like it is it normal to feel
kind of dizzy dead weary you'll get past
it in intent you know what he did man
hey oh that's a hat okay
thought it was his hair ah you're a man
me of back when I was a young land and I
mixed up the voices as in back then I
also knew someone else who would nervous
liked you this is nothing compared to
the acrobatic scam right Fred any type
then I dare you one day I'm gonna get
back today
we found them memento which means BAM
right to the noggin pachow another
headshot even no skill oh yeah give me
it give him the concussion you're lucky
I program my head to be heard as a break
you share point ahead let's go it's time
for everyone's favorite pastime berry
patch they have independent these are
actually getting okay we can't move that
one we can do this right oh it goes up
I'm an idiot
there you go it's not all done Felix
well this should well they should be oh
oh this requires some thinking look at
that genius Pierce strikes again thank
you everyone for all your oh that was an
ingrate
[Music]
aha
my bad okay maybe I wasn't a genius this
one but I would I've been seriously it's
super genius all of them okay so don't
worry about it
don't worry I know you were still
impressed don't don't hide your
impression and impression impress your
how much impressed you are damn it Barry
Sophia will you marry me
well he did warn him regret misspelled
proposal really you marry me anyone
noticed so that's why he got fired
where's semento but this is still Sofia
what is this
it's time already for genius the genius
that everyone has grown to love mr.
Khalil Burke what is that oh it's a
cello of course good thing I am a genius
what the heck
okay that's fine there you go bazinga
everybody how does he do it every time
how is it so incredibly smart I know
it's okay to be impressed it's okay to
cry in Envy it's okay seriously only one
single orb for the memory of each
proposal hey at least you remembered it
it's a good point
there's something off
why did he settle with Sofia we're gonna
find out me how are you able to pilot an
airplane but nutreve a key priorities
thanks to you
come on we're gonna be late she's sure
getting lots of screen time compared to
his wife at his proposal there's
something about her that really bothers
me
oh don't take it so personally it's not
like Colin's your heart your husband he
asked me what's the matter
you knew and think I'm gonna pass and
easily it's your first rehearsal with
them rain you're nervous it is hey
I'm not nervous and even if I were well
you being there would have a guess but I
can't always hang around you know BC
you'll be able to concentrate baby with
me hanging around without me hanging
around hey remember how you always used
to tell me about your day after school
why didn't you go ahead and you can tell
me all about it after rehearsal okay
Danny's decided by UEFA
Wow what a wacky gap interesting there's
an interesting way of storytelling
why the sudden change of tone this is
very ominous Oh
this is how he felt at the time hey Bree
hearse was about to start
chop-chop-chop-chop everybody a couple
of blank oh there it is
we got two more mementos interesting oh
that's her
that's a fear so they were alive at the
same time I thought like I don't know
it's just the right place I can't
believe I'm late
[Music]
was that Sophia I guess you
hey beautiful
so she played the piano okay stop stop
everything something was up around bar
36 from somewhere on my right side by
someone in the cello section someone
sitting in the second row towards the
front Carlin I think you are rushing
watch that I will all right let's pick
back up on from bar 35 right into the
solo that already
Hausa she's the one playing the theme Oh
it means something deep about life I
want to keep hearing it I hope it
doesn't change now so good
Tkachev kept shout I don't like catch
owl is the most satisfying word to say
it's time for everyone's favorite
pastime oh wow
alright we need the book keep forgetting
that well there's a lot of books but not
a lot of space for books but good thing
I am a funny ish
look at that okay let's activate it and
see where are we gonna be taken now oh
they're on a date what the hell what
happened with a little Fay alright I'm
done with mine
me too let's see what you what is that
my best effort dad go it on date going
on dates already you sure moves fast
well we're still skipping around
sometimes probably pairs if that's
epheus let's see yes
[Music]
I'm on Collins level gee I wonder who he
learned to draw like that from death
Satan Pixar Disney Animation Studios he
literally saw a Finding Nemo coming I
guess we're going to you oh this place
is huge
oh my god what
it's happening
oh are you feeling all right Ava so many
well it's good to have interests other
than gardening I guess I'm [ __ ] wrong
with her
a lot of shark's head too well I guess I
always loved the piano but when I was a
kid I had a piano teacher every time I
played she made me feel like the worst
pianists in the world for a while I
stopped going and stopped playing but I
guess I was a kid with no self-esteem
because it really got to me and whenever
I doubted myself I'd remember her words
one day I had enough and I said to
myself someday I'm going to be a concert
pianist
but it's not letting her dictate what
you do with your life well I guess I
have a weird way of seeing things to me
just a matter much which path I take as
long as I make the most of it
hmm there's only so little time in this
life and we'd never be able to do all
that we want so no matter what we do
there will there always be other things
to try other paths to take so in the end
I think I just have to be satisfied with
the ones that I took but I'm just
blabbering now enough about me how about
you well I made you want to become a
pilot I I wanted to fly to places that's
a
well it was because a girl a long time
ago
a friend of mine went somewhere far away
I guess I just wanted to go find them
again anything important going on up
there not sure I was staring at the
[ __ ]
okay call me when we're ready to move on
I suppose there was one way to the right
let me see if I was right
come on this jellyfish here too so
pretty this game hey they are in the
touchy pool hey where is it going oh wow
for a cephalopod
it sure is cuddly it actually kind of
take us Oh regret in attack wise is even
in the petting for the head we haven't
found the Mentos that way the master
Mentos
noni where's the master Mentos
could it be on him no it must have been
in the other room then then really makes
sense to go this way first but hey we
all make mistakes
maybe Rosaline don't take care of this
in memory will you just leave me alone
for a while I think we're done now okay
okay whatever Rosaline don't need you
it's time for everyone's favorite bed
today but do what do we need the paper
plane okay how do we get it we can't
move anything that way only move this
one so the goal is to just get it up
there but it won't do it
unless
we get one more up there okay genius
Pierce strikes again hey we're good to
move on now go on then I'll catch right
up she really loves jellyfishes huh okay
then he caught the plane we must be back
to Fay now yeah you sure you take easy
team Hey
no one's kicking me out good thing I got
my hours in time huh
you'd better hey it's gonna be a
different world Athey you ready to go
yeah in a moment you done with your
jellyfish face it's not a face in yes
what's going on here not sure yet the
place seems but the place sure looks
deserted
what a dropping no no wannabe here to
see it anyway destroy the cat calling
the airport shut down Oh yep hmm I guess
all things come to an end
this chip should look weird it being
empty hey there's someplace - you've
always liked that picture yes you've
always liked that picture yes I had them
save it for you
just a little something to remember this
place by thanks Bosch you've done good
work for us kid
honest respectful work oh and I almost
forgot
your favorite planes still here for one
more day before we move her if you wanna
give her one last flight before then
it's on the family for a nice boss
thanks boss
[Music]
I'm a going here
a brat sign doesn't their logo look like
a post logo or something better paper
plane she was 16
with the airport closing down and all
she I think it's time that I finally
tell me my emotions for you
you see well it's not going there well
there's the fright flying job I applied
for I did an interview with them the
other day I think it's I got a good
chance at it there's still a long way to
go but that'll help me build some more
flight hours to think that you've
actually came Fifi it feels like only
yesterday we were still standing in
there baby thanks for giving me the kick
I needed by the way hey Peter Everglades
hey he made progress with the lady from
her history Sofia
well we've been talking and I don't know
I might try to ask her out on a date
soon but well you know I am with that
stuff when I help me prepare
oh I'm not sure if I'd be much help
without sort of things
why is he doing but if you ate it rain
I'd say just work on making yourself
more interesting blunder yeah yes still
a work in progress
we haven't been taking this after lately
you know sometimes even when I'm here
you just do your own thing I know sorry
it's just been so busy
the good kind though right seems to me
like you've got it together
hey you want to take a bit flight the
bus of it babysit that there's a grey
grey strip near the Henry used to go
through
maybe he came to training me yeah you
coming along so do you think he was just
really dense or plain not interesting
it's odd how such a simple wish of being
happy could be so tangled up he sure
didn't make it easy on us by being
ambitious with the details here I got an
idea
no no permanent marker there now let's
get go get paid ha ha ha ha you can't
just draw him a smile like that lips are
red not black great job now he looks
like an effect affectionate Joker we've
almost burned through all the memories
haven't we
I guess the vortex should be just up
ahead
good maybe that'll help us get to the
source of what he wants as if we don't
know that already
it's her obviously there's a reason she
keeps on showing up the guys clearly got
his childhood sweetheart on his mind and
he's been asking what ifs he wants her
but he's got principles so he knows he
can't have her the perfect equation for
a sad sad man who needs our help hacking
the root of the problem are you
suggesting to remove her well if we do
you'd be the expert but whatever happens
we'd have to change something and in the
end she's the one we could alter the
most anyhow calling himself said he
should try to avoid changing things
involving his family right and out of
these memories face the only other
consistency that we keep coming back to
I guess you're right we should start
with her and work our way up from there
but something still doesn't add up
hello oh my god is her could you be
there it's me
Roxy am here Oh how's it going in me
awesomely of course how are you doing
did you bring the paperwork yeah I
brought the paperwork every
I also brought bribe what I can't stand
that guy
I can hear you hi Rob Hey anyway you
guys win a came every equate to get the
paper back then
really we're kind of on a roll here
maybe we should just ask him to help us
with the paper oh and by the way Neil I
was gonna ask about the machine I think
I shot I'm heading out get their firms
ready for our filling wait what oh yeah
there was something in the beginning you
know the protocol Yvette Collins our
patient now and one of us has to check
the forms yeah but we let others help
before in the headquarters never cared
maybe we should have cared even Oh a
click - I don't know why
when were you born four bronica in my
voice anyway let's get that last memory
link while I'm gone well yeah I won't
take long and call me when we're ready
to go to the next memory I don't want to
miss it hey strange
act 2 you don't have to leave anymore
interesting I don't know it was act
divided and seem like acting I guess the
story is gonna change Sam let me get
these three you took you take apart the
whole machine because the maintenance
department sucks but look it was the
easiest way had I just left it in the
company's process it would never have
gotten done much like there's paperwork
my gosh I just realized you're talking
and writing at the same time that's
amazing I hope I didn't cause you to
make a mistake I am so sorry you know
sometimes even I can tell if you're
being sarcastic and that's saying a lot
come to think of it you actually remind
me a bit of someone from this patients
memory
she's whacking all over the place - ah I
bet I would have loved to meet her I'm
sure you would have too bad we're gonna
have to do something about her anyhow
whoosh the paperwork's done insane
[Music]
thanks for bringing the docs rocks I'm
gonna check on Carly
oh you're just gonna get away like that
you met a fool even rap but did you
think you could fool a fairly technician
I did it quick diagnostically
seems like you've done more than just
removing the stabilizing the machine
you're using isn't even the your
official sigmund equipment is it because
you're registered machine is back at
headquarters in your office I don't know
what you're up to but I'm gonna faint
him hey Rob how's the situation look
it's fine I was just talking with a
medical doctor and what's for the
murderous atmosphere I'll ride your
tripping again yeah no I'm not in fact
tripping again is everything okay in
here swimmingly neighbors is gonna go
check on candy yeah I'm gonna go check
on Collin
good bye Carly
huh a whole lifetime of memories and we
barely ran into any of the nice ones
okay is that there is try to leave in be
disturbances only make my job harder
taking a breather huh
paperwork mostly how's he looking
Colin it's okay so far but you guys sure
are starting things up in there stirring
things up what do you mean it's this
brain activity it's been abnormally high
for a sedated patient
try not to eggs eggs agra agra wait him
too much in there wait what but we
haven't been doing anything different
company compared to any other patient
hey I'm only telling you what I see
anyway just try and keep it in mind I'll
continue to monitor his status
huh where'd your mother go I think she
went to the Attic
oh hey Mei attack for it to your private
firmament well yeah all right come on
what's up there's something I wanted to
ask you it's about my father's tuition
what you saw in there you know that's
confidential right yes but you must know
what it's like being the family of a
patient undergoing this procedure to be
honest my mother was always against it
and I wasn't a big fan either but their
father was to take on a new life worth
of memories
well I knowing what and why would at
least help me come in terms with it so
please could you tell me reveal info
about Colin you know your father
actually visited for something wish for
something completely unremarkable he
just asked to be happy that's all I
guess he certainly isn't huh
well you know you shouldn't looking at
it that way people are always gonna have
cravings and longings and for what-ifs
he's just curious about grass on the
other side of the fence that's all as
humans are I suppose but hey it really
did ask for you and your mother to stay
part of his new life
that helps for what it's worth thanks
doc good luck with the rest of it I hope
something works out what happened we'll
do what we can
let's check on Sofia and the Attic then
what Oh
she's sitting here
who's Amon I want to go to that eh
Oh ever Rosaleen okay okay okay great
hey vac do you hear me Nia Neil yep
how's it going in there just trying to
find the last memory link well she
started sure taking a lot longer than I
did still there was only one lap yeah I
just I don't know I've looked everywhere
but this game shows there's one more
here somewhere and I'm gonna find it
are you done with the paperwork well I
just damn it where are my pills I better
not have left them in the car again hey
you're still weird what is happening the
subplot sorry I'm not finished with the
paperwork yet uh how long does it take
to fill in change some papers it's
almost ready I'll come back as soon as
it's done all right just make it quick
Shh
it shouldn't take that long to get back
to the to go to the car and back what
about the pills men interesting
oh yes we're checking on the Wi-Fi
listen what is this you're out early
just needed to take care of some things
I'm heading back soon that's good we're
down to connecting most of the pass
through callings memories by the way if
you'd like I could tell you about the
things we found I thought that would be
considered confidential yeah but you're
his wife I personally think you deserve
to know thanks but I'm okay aren't you
at least bit curious about the things we
found sure and there was a time when I
haven't been dying to know every detail
but now I think it matters don't think
it matter much anymore perhaps you know
some things I don't maybe it even
changed my view of things still even
then I'd just be another incomplete
piece of reality and after a lifetime
where all is said and done I feel like
the best I could do is simply stay with
the reality
I've come to peace with the risks
however something I wanted to ask only
because it feels like it's meant for me
did you find anything about why Colin
put this book here and like this no I
was actually gonna ask you about it he's
had it for a long time now but he kept
on replacing its pages and now it's just
filled with pieces of blank paper if you
find something about it that's meant for
me please do let me know that's all I
asked
understood I'll keep an eye out for it
hey wait
doctor what's right I know I haven't
been the most welcoming and you probably
know why by now but I know you're just
hated do your job so thank you for
helping him yeah no hard feelings okay
let's go to the card if I remember it's
the elevators in it I want answers I
want answers of the plot it's not it's
not telling me it's not telling us
anything it's still good it's still
interesting but I'm not come on these
guys in potato misty can be she oh it's
you again
thanks for taking a bit sterling the pan
for me I'd really appreciate it oh yeah
is that your mother she hot it's okay I
hope you traumatize that kid huh she's
been picking on my potato for years it's
time she learned her lesson and now that
I got even a smaller potato I was really
starting to worry about the future you
named your other kid potato - of course
not don't be silly it's just a nickname
it's real name spud yeah that's way
better baby baby we different it man fit
you're here to visit old man Colin you
know Colin yeah he wants literally be
available for me did I use that word
right now mom no dear you meant
figuratively
oh boy what a mess so anyway how's your
six like oh my god the room reference
lad
last week Owen gave me his leftover jar
of lemon juice I haven't seen him since
then now could you please give it back
to him
wait lemon juice what for to write spy
messages of course it's invisible ink
I've already been to secret Lannisters
but for when he can we do old man Colin
said he was already done using it so I
could buy the whole jar
lucky me so could you give the Jerry
back to Kelly well I don't think Colin
needs it anymore you could probably keep
it maybe maybe
wow what a loser okay potato it's time
to head back home ever are you calling
from the machine
yeah at least his function still working
normally hey listen I think I might have
figured out something about Colin's
notebook that's not important right now
I need you to check something for me
what is that is everything okay in there
did you find the last memory link no are
you at the other computer I can be good
could you run and record search of a and
search for any aviation accidents Oh No
you think she was in a plane crash I
just want to rule the possibility of
something else I'll send you her in
strata profile there's enough data even
without a last name let me know when you
have the results okay interesting so
we're not going to we need yeah exactly
we need his pills for some reason
hello hey Rox you're still at a your
laptop right yeah pop I just forwarded a
profile - you mind helping me running
our record check what is his voice oh my
god
sure mind telling me where you're at me
the misty uh okie dokie Loki Poe get
settled in a car you're back with the
results
thank you very much okay let's get the
damn pills it's really bothering me I
don't know why okay good no one's at the
front desk to bother us okie dokie Loki
dokie
oh my god hey I'm still working on that
Neil can you hear me
yes hello are you think I'm right here
what is it Neil if you can hear me
listen I don't think she ever uh are you
still there
weird the car must be malfunctioning
I'll fix it as soon as I get back you
need to hurry the F up dude sprint this
is serious I guess we've been here for a
couple hours huh
what
alright Chuck the map that could I say
huh huh that's a nice bike sure wish I
had one like it
ever what happened earlier now it's Roxy
your silly party uh how so how's that
record search going
oh it's going just great
actually no it's not great at all well
what Rob saying is that it depends on
your perspective what it's a yes or no
question did she die in a plane crash or
no way so here's the great part there's
no plane crash to her record so you
don't have to worry about that she's why
don't you just say so I simple know what
I'm surprised well that's not everything
the thing is not only is there no plane
crash but there's nothing else to her
record either in fact there is no record
of a I say no record available to public
domain as in no record in existence
anywhere we've checked the cumulative
public record the private ID Network
databases even where well even a few
places that we technically don't have
access to still there is no record of
her for anything no death not even Brett
uh-huh so unless Colin's got some
extreme form of distortive amnesiac
condition he doesn't I checked yes oh oh
sorry I got another cup hello we better
hurry back act 3 I don't know act even
if it was just someone like me I guess
we're going back in then
hey where are you two going company call
we got another patient coming live
across town yeah get a hat siren you
night call huh should have taken a nap
yeah we're all used to it by now seems
like you got a handful to sort out
yourself huh yes if what we yielded
means what I think it means you might be
in for a tricky evening at least from
our experience patients capable of that
tend to be rather peculiar cases I've
read the patient's case by the way
care for a word of advice well you're
probably gonna give it anyway so I don't
know the details of collie night but
this reminds me of a case we've done
just try to remember that making someone
happy isn't only about finding the
answers it could also be advice shaping
the question anyhow good luck by the way
don't think you're getting after hook
easy after this is done you got some
explaining to do don't you and it's
gonna be so much fat see it I'm making
parity oh oh wait something just
occurred to me although I'm not sure why
yet I do know that you removed the
machines
stabilizer but with the patient
subconsciousness being near aware to the
system processor well I hope you got a
back-up plan if he's able to get around
its single-thread firewall
I'm gonna have to end that episode there
it's getting really interesting the
story has really changed a lot this
episode let me know what you think I'm
told that the game is five hours and I
think we're four hours and so next
episode will probably be the last thank
you for all their support and I'll see
you tomorrow hopefully with another one
stay awesome